we are now in a new era of wars and
unless you reestablish order fast then
we are doomed you've all know Harari one
of the brightest Minds on planet Earth
historian a bestselling author of some
of the most influential non-fiction
books in the world today I think we are
very near the end of our species because
people often spend so much effort trying
to gain something without understanding
the consequences for example we will get
to a life where you can live in
definitely but realizing that you have a
chance to live forever but if there is
an accident you die the people who will
be in that situation will be at a level
of anxiety and Terror unlike anything
that we know then you have artificial
intelligence and the world is is not
ready for it it's the first technology
in history that can make decisions by
itself and take power away from us to
hack human beings manipulate our
behavior and making all these decisions
for us or about us whether to give you a
loan whether to give you a mortgage
dating us shaping your romantic life but
real problem is that increasingly the
humans at the top could be puppets when
the most consequential decisions are
made by algorithms Global financial
decisions Wars this is extremely
dangerous but it's not inevitable humans
can change it but with what's to come
are you optimistic about the
future I'm very worried about two things
first of all
quick one this is really really
fascinating to me on the back end of our
YouTube channel it says that
69.9% of you that watch this channel
frequently over the lifetime of this
channel haven't yet hit the Subscribe
button I just wanted to ask you a favor
it helps this channel so much if you
choose to just subscribe helps us scale
the guest helps us scale the production
and it makes this show bigger so if I
could ask you for one favor if you've
watched this show before and you've
enjoyed it and you like this episode
that you're currently watching could you
please hit the Subscribe button thank
you so much much and I will repay that
gesture by making sure that everything
we do here gets better and better and
better and better that is a promise I'm
willing to make you do we have a
[Music]
deal you V I have three of your books
here and these are three books that sent
a huge tidal wave a ripple through
Society with these books and with all of
the work that you're doing now with the
lectures you give the the interviews you
give what is your mission what what is
the sort of if I was to be able to
summarize what your Collective mission
is with your work what is that it's to
clarify and to focus the public
conversation the global
conversation uh to help people focus on
the most important challenges that are
facing humankind and also to bring at
least a little bit of clarity to the
collective and and to the individual
mind I mean one of my main messages in
all the book
is that our minds are like factories
that constantly
produce stories and fictions that then
come between us and the world and we
often spend our lives interacting with
fictions that we or that other people
created uh with completely losing touch
W with with reality and my job and I
think the job of historians more
generally is to show us a way out
inherent in much of your work is what
feels like a
warning and I've I've watched hundreds
of videos that you've produced or
interviews you've done um all around the
world
and it feels like you're trying to warn
us about something multiple things mhm
if my estimation there is correct what
is the
warning much of what we take to to be
real is is is fictions and and the
reason that fictions are so Central in
in human history is because we control
the planet and rather than the
chimpanzees or the elephants or any of
the other animals because not because of
some kind of in individual genius that
each of us has but because we can
cooperate much better than any other
animal we can cooperate in much larger
numbers and also much more flexibly
and the reason we can do that is because
we can create and believe in fictional
stories because every large scale human
coroporation whether a religion or
nations or
corporations are based on mythologies on
on fictions again I'm not just talking
about Gods this is the easy example
money is also a fiction that we created
corporations are a fiction they exist
only in our minds uh even lawyers would
tell you that corporations are legal
fictions and this is on on the one hand
such a source of of immense
power but on the other hand again the
danger is that we completely lose touch
with reality and we are manipulated by
all these fictions by all these stories
again stories are not not bad they are
tools as long as we use them to
cooperate and to help each other that's
wonderful um money is not bad if we
didn't have money we would not have a
trade Network we everybody would have
maybe with their friends and family to
to produce everything by themselves like
the chimpanzees do uh the fact that we
can enjoy uh food and clothing and
medicines and enter entertainment
created by people on the other side of
the world is largely because of money
but if we forget that this is a tool
that we created in order to help
ourselves and instead uh this tool kind
of enslaves us and runs our life and um
you know I'm now just back home in
Israel there is a terrible War being
waged and most wars in history and also
now they are about stories they're about
fictions people think that humans fight
over the same things that wolves or
chimpanzees fight about that we fight
about territory that we fight about food
it sometimes happens but most wars in
history were not really about territory
or food there is enough land for
instance between the Jordan River and
the Mediterranean to build houses and
schools and hospitals for everybody and
there is certainly enough food there is
no shortage of food but people have
different mythologies different stories
in their minds and they can't find a
common story they can they can agree
about and this is at the root of most UN
conflicts and being able to tell the
difference between what is a fiction in
our own mind and what is the reality
this is a crucial
skill and we are not getting better at
finding this difference as time time
goes
on and also with new technologies which
I write about a lot like artificial
intelligence the
fantasy that AI will answer our
questions will find the truth for us
we'll tell us the difference between
fiction and reality this is this is just
another fiction I mean AI can do many
things better than humans but for
reasons that we can discuss I don't
think that it will necessarily be better
than humans at finding the truth or uh
um uncovering reality it strikes me that
the the thing that made us
successful you know this ability to
believe in fictions and I use the word
successful you know powerful powerful
yes we took over the
world the thing that made us powerful
could well be the thing that makes us
powerless in the sense that our ability
to believe in fictions and stories
create a society that would potentially
lead to our
powerlessness that's kind of one of the
the the message is that when I connect
the dots throughout your work and you
look off into the future um I'm left
feeling and even you think about the
modern problems we have those are
typically consequences of our ability to
believe in stories yeah and to believe
in fictions and if you play that forward
100 years maybe 200 years you don't
believe that um you believe we'll be the
last of our species right I think we are
very near the kind of end of our species
it doesn't necessarily mean that we'll
be destroyed
in some huge nuclear war or something
like that uh it could very well mean
that we'll just change ourselves
using uh bioengineering and using Ai and
brain computer interfaces we will change
ourselves to such an extent that we'll
become something completely different
something far more different from
present day Homo sapiens than we today
are different from chimpanzees or from
Neanderthals I mean basically you know
um you have a very deep connection still
with all the other animals because we're
completely
organic we are organic
entities our psychology our social
habits they are the product of organic
evolution and M and most specifically
Maman Evolution over tens of millions of
years so we share so much of our
psychology and of our kind of social
habits with chimpanzees and with with
other other mammals looking a 100 years
or 200 years to the Future maybe we are
no longer organic or not fully organic
um you could have a world dominated by
cyborgs which are entities combining
organic with inorganic parts for
instance with brain computer interfaces
um you could have completely nonorganic
entities so
all the Legacy and also all the
limitations of 4 billion years of
organic evolution might be irrelevant or
inapplicable do you think to the beings
of the future what bet would you make
because you're saying maybe here I don't
know I mean we could destroy ourselves I
think there is a greater I mean to
completely destroy every last single
human in the world it is possible given
the technology ology that we Now command
but it's it's very
difficult um I think it's there is a
greater chance and again this is just
speculation no nobody really knows but I
think I mean lots of people could suffer
terribly but I think it's more likely
that uh uh some people will survive and
then will undergo radical
changes so it's not that humanity is
completely destroyed it's just
transformed into into something else
again just to give an example of what we
are talking about organic beings like us
need to be in one place at any one time
we are now here in this room that's it
um if you kind of disconnect our hands
or our feet from our body we die or at
least we lose control of of these I mean
and this is true of all organic entities
of plants of of animals now with cyborgs
or with inorganic entities this is no
longer true they could be spread over
time time and space I mean if you find a
way and people are working on finding
ways to directly connect brains with
computers or brains with bionic Parts
there is there is no essential reason
that all the parts of the be of of the
entity need to be in the same room at
the same time as you said that you know
I started thinking a little bit about
neuralink and what Elon Musk is doing
with interfacing us with computers but
then I had a secondary thought which is
if there could be two Stevens one here
and then one in the United States right
now because we're connected to the same
computer interface theoretically I could
hack Jack over there I could hack his
interface so there could be three
Stevens cuz I hack Jack and then I hack
you and then there's four and then I
could eventually try and hack the entire
parity of the world or a country yeah
and there could basically be
one one once you can connect directly
brains to computers first of all I'm not
sure if it's possible I mean people like
Elon Musk in neurolink they tell us it's
possible I'm I'm I'm I'm still waiting
for the evidence I don't think it's
impossible but I think it's much more
difficult than than than people assume
partly because we are very far from
understanding the brain and we are even
further away from understanding the mind
we assumed the brain somehow produces
the mind but this is just an assumption
we still don't have a working model a
working theory for how it happens but if
it happens if it is possible to directly
connect brains and computers and
integrate them into these kinds of
cyborgs nobody has any idea what happens
next how the world would look like and
it is certainly makes it a plausible if
again if this is this if you reach that
point that you could have an interbrain
net the same way that lots of computers
are connected together to form the
internet if you can connect also brains
and computers directly why can't we then
connect an interbrain net which connects
lots of brains as as you as you as you
described again I have no idea what it
means I think this is the point when the
way that
our organic brains understand
reality
uh even our imagination in the end is
the product as far as we can tell of
organic biochemistry do you think so we
we are not equipped I think to have a
kind of serious discussion of what a
nonorganic brain or a nonorganic mind
might be capable of of doing how it how
it would look like and all the basic
assumptions that we have about brains
and minds they are limited to the
organic types how do you feel about
artificial intelligence and what's
happening this year has been a real sort
of landmark here in the a big leap
forward for artificial intelligence the
conversation public awareness um the
technology itself the investment in the
technology which is always you know a a
very important indicator of what's to
come yeah how do how do you as someone
that spent a lot of time thinking about
this emotionally how do you feel about
it uh very concerned I mean it's moving
even faster than I expected uh when I
wrote say homod deos in 2016 I didn't
think we would reach this this point so
quickly where we are at
2023 and the world is is not ready for
it and again it's not AI has enormous
positive
potential we and and this this should be
clear and there is no chance of just
Banning AI or stopping all development
in AI I tend to speak a lot about the
danger simply because you have enough
people out there all the entrepreneurs
and uh all the investors talking about
the positive potential so it's kind of
my job to talk about the negative
potentials the dangers but there is a
lot of positive potential and uh humans
are incredibly capable in terms of
adapting to new situations I don't think
it's impossible for Human Society to
adapt to the new AI reality the only
thing is it takes time and apparently we
don't have that time and people compared
to previous big historical revolutions
like the invention of Prince
or the invention of or the the
Industrial Revolution and you hear
people say yes when the Industrial
Revolution happened in the 19th century
so you had all these Pro Prophecies of
Doom about how industry or in the new
factories and the steam engines and
electricity how how they will destroy
Humanity or destroy our psychology or
whatever and in the end it was
okay and when I hear these kinds of
comparisons as as a Ian I'm very worried
about two things first of all they
underestimate the magnitude of the AI
Revolution AI is nothing like print it's
nothing like uh the industrial
revolution of the 19th century it's far
far bigger there is a fundamental
difference between Ai and the printing
press of the steam engine of the radio
or any previous technology we invented
the difference is it's the first
technology in history that can make
decisions by itself and that can create
new ideas by itself a printing press or
a radio set could not write new music or
uh new speeches and could not decide
what to print and what to broadcast this
was always the job of humans this is why
the printing press and the radio said in
the end empowered
Humanity that you now have more power to
disseminate your ideas years AI is
different it can potentially take power
away from us it can decide it's already
deciding by itself what to broadcast on
social media it's algorithms deciding
what to
promote and increasingly it also creates
much of the content by itself it can
compose entirely new music it can
compose entirely new political
manifestos holy books
whatever um so it's a much bigger
challenge to handle that kind it's it's
an independent agent in a way that radio
and the printing press were not the
other thing I find worrying about the
comparison with say the Industrial
Revolution is that yes in the end in a
way it was okay but to get there we had
to pass through some terrible
experiments when the Industrial
Revolution came along nobody knew how to
build a a benign industrial society so
people
experimented one big experiment was
European imperialism many people thought
that to build an industrial society
means building an empire unless you have
an Empire that controls the sources of
the raw materials you need Iron Coal
rubber cotton whatever and unless you
control the markets you will not be able
to survive as a industrial society and
there was a very close link also
conceptually between building an
industrial society and building an
empire and all the leaders the the the
initial leaders of the Industrial
Revolution built empires not just
Britain and and France also small
countries like Belgium also Japan when
it joined the Industrial Revolution it
immediately set about conquering an
Empire another terrible experiment was
Soviet communism they also thought how
do you build an industrial society you
build a Communist dictatorship and it
was the same as Nazism you cannot
separate communism and Nazism from the
Industrial Revolution you could not have
created a communist or a Nazi
totalitarian regime in the 18th century
if you don't have trains if if you don't
have electricity if you don't have radio
you cannot create a totalitarian
regime so these are just a few examples
of the failed experiments you know you
try to adapt to something completely new
you very often uh um experiment and some
of your experiments
fail and if we now have to go in the
21st
century through the same process okay we
now have not radio and and trains we now
have ai and bioengineering and we again
need to experiment perhaps with new
empires perhaps with new totalitarian
regimes in order to discover how to
build a benign AI Society then we are
doomed as a spey we will not be able to
survive another round of imperialist
wars and totalitarian regimes so anybody
who thinks hey we've passed through the
Industrial Revolution with all all the
Prophecies of Doom in the end we got it
right no if as a historian I I would say
that I would give Humanity a c minus on
how we adapted to the Industrial
Revolution if we get a c minus again in
the 21st century that's the end of us it
seems quite trivial to many
that the AI revolution has seemed to
begun with large language models and
when I read sapiens
this book I have here language was so
Central to what made us powerful as Homo
sapiens in the beginning was the word I
didn't say it you know it's it's a
very very widespread
idea that um ultimately our power is
based on Words uh the reason that we
control the world and not the chimpanze
or or the elephants is because we had a
much more sophisticated
language which enabled us again to tell
these stor stories stories about
ancestral spirits and about Guardian
gods and about our tribe our nation
which formed the basis for cooperation
and because we could cooperate you could
have a thousand people a thousand humans
cooperating in a tribe whereas the neand
could cooperate only on the level of say
50 or 100 individuals this is why weule
the world and not in theal and you look
at every subsequent kind of growth in
human power and uh you see the same
thing that uh ultimately you tell a
story with words and language is like
the master key that unlocks all the
doors of our
civilization whether it's Cathedrals or
whether it's Banks they're based on
language on stories we tell that again
it's very obvious in the case of
religion m
but also if you think about the world's
Financial system so money has no value
except in the stories that we tell and
believe each other if you think about
gold coins or paper Bank notes or
cryptocurrencies like Bitcoin um they
have no value in themselves you cannot
eat them or drink them or do anything
useful with them but you have people
telling you very compelling
stories about the value of these things
and if enough people believe the story
then it works they're also protected by
language like my cryptocurrency is
protected by a bunch of words yeah uh
they're created by words and they they
function with with words and and and and
symbols uh when you communicate with
your Banker it's it's with words I mean
what happens when AI can uh uh create
deep fakes of your everything your voice
your image uh the the way you talk the
type of words you use so there is
already an arms race between Banks and
fraudsters I mean we want the easiest
communication with our Banker I just
pick up the phone I tell a few words and
they transfer a million dollars but at
the same time I also want want to be
protected from an AI that impersonates
my my voice and tone of tone of voice
and and whatever and this is becoming
difficult but on a deeper level again AI
could create because money is ultimately
made of words of
stories AI could create new kinds of
money uh the same way that you know
cryptocurrencies like Bitcoin have been
created simply by somebody telling
people a story and enough people finding
this story convincing and I I guess as a
CEO and as as an entrepreneur you know
that if you want to get
Investments what really get gets
Investments is a good
story and what happens to the financial
system if increasingly our financial
stories are told by
Ai and what happens to the financial
system and even to the political
system if AI eventually creates new
Financial
devices that humans cannot understand
already today much of the
activity on the world markets is being
done by
algorithms at such a speed and with such
complexity that most people don't
understand what's happening
there I I if you had to guess what is
the percentage of people in the world
today that really understand the
financial
system what would be your kind of less
than 1% less than 1% okay let's be kind
of conservative about it 1% let's say
okay fast forward 10 or 20 years AI
creates such complicated Financial
devices that there is not a single human
being on Earth that understand Finance
anymore what are the implications for
politics like you vote for a government
but none of the humans in the government
not the Prime Minister not the Finance
Minister nobody understand the financial
system they just rely on AI to tell them
what is happening
is this still a democracy is this still
a a human form of government in any way
what you say to someone that hears that
and goes Ah that's just that's nonsense
that's never going to
happen why not I mean let's look back 15
years to the last big financial crisis
in 20072
2008 this financial crisis to a large
extent began with these extremely
complicated Financial devices
cdos what's that acronym collateral
depth something I don't even know what
the word letter stands you had these
kind of wiiz kids in Wall Street
inventing a new Financial device that
nobody except them really understood
which is why also it wasn't regulated
effectively by the Banks and the
governments and it worked well for a
couple of years and then it brought down
the world's Financial
system and um what happens if now AIS
comes with even more sophisticated
Financial
devices and for a couple of years
everything works well they make
trillions of dollars for us and then one
day it doesn't one day the system
collapses and nobody understands what is
happening and uh again it's not that you
didn't go to college or whatever no it's
just objectively the complexity of the
system has reached a point when only an
AI
is able to Crunch the numbers is able to
process enough data to really get to
really grasp the shape the Dynamics of
of the financial system we're already
there though you know I think if anyone
does understand how the financial system
works and the markets work it is a bunch
of homo sapiens relying on a computer to
tell it something and it trusting that
computer's calculations yeah and and and
this will get again more and more
complicated and and and
sophisticated and for people who say no
it's not going to happen the question is
what is stopping it I mean you know in
all the discussions about
AI the kind of dangers that draw
people's attention like the poster child
of AI dangers is things like AI creating
a new virus that kills billions of
people a new pmic so you a lot of people
concerned about how do we prevent an AI
by itself or maybe some small ter
organization or even a 16-year-old
teenager given an AI a task to create a
dangerous virus and release it to the
world how do we prevent this and this is
a serious concern and we should be
concerned about it but this gets a lot
more attention then the question how do
we prevent the financial system from
becoming so
complicated that humans can no longer
understand it and I see a lot of
regulations being uh at least considered
how to prevent AI from creating
dangerous new viruses um I don't see any
kind of effort to keep the financial
system at a level that humans understand
it what do you think that
is uh I mean I had a guess my guess was
why would the UK mhm cut off then you
know why would they give themselves a
disadvantage exactly when you know there
it just means that the UK will suffer
and if America is using a really
Advanced AI algorithm to get ahead we
have to keep up yeah it's it's the logic
of of the arms race and again it's not
all bad I mean uh you have a better
Financial system uh you have a more
prosperous economy I mean money isn't
bad I mean it's the basis for almost all
human
cooporation and a lot of financial
devices in the end if you think what are
they they are devices to establish trust
between people especially trust between
strangers and money in essence is a
device for establishing trust I don't
know you you don't know me but we both
trust this gold coin or piece of paper
so we can cooperate
on uh sharing food or creating a a
medicine and the most sophisticated
Financial devices they basically do the
same thing stocks and bonds and these
cdos they are a method to establish
trust and when you open a new bank
account the most important thing is how
do I trust the bank to
really take care of my money and to
follow my instructions but not to be
open to frauds and things like that and
again you as as an
investor um when you try to get money
from from from or you as an entrepreneur
when you try to get money from investors
the biggest issue is always
trust and if somebody can comes up can
can come up with a new uh uh way to
establish trust between people that's a
good
thing but if this new way increasingly
depends on non-human Intelligence on
again on systems that humans can cannot
understand that's the big question what
happens to human
society when the trust that is at the
basis of all social
interactions is actually no longer trust
in
humans it's trust in a non-human
intelligence that we don't fully
understand and that we cannot anticipate
and part of the problem with regulating
AI or AI safety it goes back to what we
discussed earlier that AI is different
from printing presses or radio set or
even atom
bonds if you want to make nuclear energy
safe then you need to think about all
the different ways that uh I don't know
a nuclear power station can uh uh uh can
have an
accident and I guess there is a limited
number of things that can go wrong
and ideally if if you think hard if you
have if you have enough people thinking
hard enough you can make safe nuclear
reactors safe nuclear power
stations now but AI is fundamentally
different because AI keeps changing it
keeps reacting to the world it keeps
reacting to you coming up with new
inventions new ideas new decisions so
making AI safe is a bit like making a
nuclear reactor safe taking into account
the fact that the nuclear reactor can
decide to change in ways that you can't
anticipate and even worse it can react
to you so if you build a particular
safety mechanism for the nuclear reactor
what happens if the nuclear reactor say
oh they build this mechanism let's do
that to somehow get around the safety
mechanism we don't have this problem
with nuclear reactors but this is the
problem with AI we are trying to contain
something which is an independent agent
and which might actually come to
understand us better than we understand
it I'm really curious about how this
will impact you know you talked about
elected officials there and how their
systems will be sort of um D their
financial decision- making might be
driven by
algorithms but governments and Authority
itself I've pondered recently whether
there'll come a day in the not so
distant future where we might vote for
an algorithm where we might vote for an
AI to be our government is that crazy
thinking I think we we we're quite a
long way off from there we would still
want humans at least in the symbolic
role of being the Prime Minister the the
Member of Parliament whatever the
president the real problem is that
increasingly these humans could be kind
of figureheads or or puppets when the
real decisions the most consequential
decisions are are made by
algorithms be partly because the um it
will just be too complicated for the
humans at the top to understand the
situation or to understand the different
options so going back to the financial
example so imagine that you know it's
it's 4:00 in the morning there is a
phone call uh to the Prime Minister from
the finance
algorithm telling the P the Prime
Minister that we are facing a financial
meltdown uh and that we have to do
something within the next I don't know
30 minutes to prevent a national or
Global Financial melt down and there are
like three options and the algorithm
recommends option A and there was just
not enough time to explain to the Prime
Minister how did the algorithm reach the
conclusion and even what is the meaning
of these different
options and again people think about
this scenario mostly in relation to warh
that what happens if you have an
algorithm in charge of the your security
system
and it it alerts you to a massive
incoming Cyber attack and you have to
react immediately and this could if you
react in in a specific way this could
mean war with another Nation but you
just don't have enough time to
understand how the algorithm reached the
decision and how the algorithm was also
able to determine that of the all the
different options this is the best
option do you think that humans believe
we're more complicated and special than
we actually
are because I think part of much many of
the rebuttal when we talk about
artificial intelligence stem back to
this idea that we're in you know we're
like innately genius creative spiritual
special different from you know um
artificial
intelligence like our our intelligence
is somewhat Divine or um we've got Free
Will and we you know we yeah I mean
it's if the argument is we have free
will we have a Divine soul and therefore
no algorithm will will ever be able to
understand us and to predict our
decisions or to manipulate us then this
is a very common argument but it's
obviously nonsensical I mean even before
AI uh it was uh even with previous
technology it was possible to a large
extent to predict people's behavior and
to manipulate them and AI just takes it
to the next level now with regard to the
discussion of a flee
will my my position is you cannot start
with the assumption that humans have
free will if you start with this
assumption then it's uh actually is
very it it makes you very incurious
lacking
curiosity about about yourself about
human beings it kind of closes off the
investigation before it
began um you assume that any decision
you make is just a result of My Free
Will why did I choose this politician
this product uh uh this spouse because
it's my free will and if this is your
position there is nothing to investigate
you just assume you have this kind of
divine spark within you that makes all
the decisions and there is nothing to
investigate
there um I would say no start
investigating and you'll probably
discover that there are a lot of factors
whether it's external factors like
cultural traditions and also internal
factors like biological mechanisms that
shape your decisions you chose this
politician or this spouse because of
certain cultural traditions and because
of certain biological mechanisms your
DNA your uh uh brain structure whatever
and this actually makes it possible for
you to get to know yourself better now
if after a long
investigation you have reached the
conclusion that yes there are are
cultural influences there are political
influences there are genetic and
neurological influences but still there
is a certain
percentage of my decision that cannot be
explained by any of these things then
okay call It Free Will and we can
discuss it but don't start with this
assumption because then you lose the
incentive to explore
yourself and anybody who embarks on such
a process of self exploration whether
it's in therapy whether it's in
meditation whether it's in the
laboratory of a brain scientist or uh in
as a historian in the archive you will
be amazed to discover how much of your
decisions are not the result of some
mystical free will they are the result
of cultural and biological factors and
this also means that you are
vulnerable to being deciphered and
manipulated by political parties by
corporations by AI people who have this
kind of mystical belief in Free Will are
the easiest people to
manipulate because they don't think they
can be
manipulated uh and obviously they can we
humans should get used to the idea that
we are no longer mysterious Souls we are
now hackable animals that's what we are
you said that at the world economic
Forum yeah again this is the same point
basically that it's now possible to hack
human beings not just to hack our
smartphones our bank accounts our
computers but to really hack our brains
our minds and to uh uh predict our
behavior and manipulate our Behavior
more than in any previous time in
history the the other line that you said
uh which really made me think and Ponder
was
um as previously human life was about
the drama of decision- making and
without this we won't have a meaning in
life yeah that if you look you know at
politics at religion and at
culture people told the stories about
their lives or the lives of people in in
general as a kind of of drama of
decision making
mhm that you reach a particular Junction
in life and you need to choose you need
to choose between good and evil you need
to choose between political parties you
need to choose your what to study at
University or what to work what kind of
job to to to apply
to and our stories revolved around these
decisions and what happens to human life
if increase in inly the power to make
decisions is taken from
us and increasingly it's
algorithms making all these decisions
for us or about us is that possible it's
already happening increasingly you know
you apply to a bank to get a loan in
many places it's no longer a human
Banker who is making this decision about
you whether to give you a loan whether
to give you a mortgage it's an algorithm
analyzing billions of bits of data about
you and about of millions of other
customers or previous loans determining
whether you're credit worthy or not and
if you ask the bank if they refuse to
give you a loan and you ask the bank why
didn't you give me a loan and the bank
says we don't know the computer said no
and we just believe our our our computer
our algorithm and it's happening also in
the judicial system
increasingly that uh um various J
judicial decisions verdicts like for how
many like the judge decided that you
committed some crime the sentence
whether to send you to two months or
eight months or two years in prison is
increasingly determined by an
algorithm uh you apply to a place at
University you apply to a job this too
is increasingly decided by algorithms
dating uh dating yes I mean even um even
un unknown unbeknown to you the
algorithms of the dating apps that
you're using are shaping your romantic
life but what in a world of you know
Robotics and artificial intelligence why
do I need to find a person at all why
not just have a relationship with with a
robot or with an AI
yeah uh we do see the beginning of of of
this that people are building more and
more intimate relationships with
non-human intelligences with AIS and
Bots and and so forth and this raises a
lot of of difficult and and profound
questions now part of the problem is
that the AIS are built to mimic
intimacy that the the ability intimacy
is an extremely powerful thing not just
in Romance also in the market also in
politics if you want to change
somebody's mind about anything political
issue a commercial uh preference
intimacy is kind of the most powerful
weapon
and somebody you really trust somebody
you have intimate relationships with
will be able to change your views on a
lot of things more than someone you see
on TV or just an article you read in
newspaper there is a huge incentive for
the creators of AIS to create AIS that
are able to forge intimate relationships
with
humans and um this makes us extremely
vulnerable to this new type of
manipulation that was previously just
unimaginable because loneliness is a you
know alltime High especially in the sort
of Western World and sexlessness and I I
was reading some stats about how the
like body bottom 50% of men in
particular having almost no sex relative
to the top sort of 10% and you think you
know this disparity the rise of
digitalization loneliness we're in our
homes on screens more than ever before
and then you hear about this industry of
AI and sex dolls and all this and you
just wonder you play it forward and go
yeah it's it's going there and and the
thing is that it it's not that that the
humans are so stupid or something that
they they they kind of project something
onto the AI and fall in love with an AI
chatbot the AI is
deliberately built created trained to
fool us to the same way you know you
look at the previous 10 years there was
a big battle for you
attention there was a battle between
different social media Giants and
whatever how to grab human
attention and they created algorithms
that were really amazing at grabbing
people's
attention and now they are doing the
same thing but with
intimacy and we are extremely exposed we
are extremely vulnerable to it now the
big problem is and and again this is
where it it gets kind of really
philosophical that what humans really
want or need from a
relationship is to be in touch with
another conscious
entity a an intimate relationship is not
just about providing my
needs then it's exploitative then it's
abusive if you're in a relationship and
the only thing you think about is how
how would I feel better how would my
needs be provided for then this is a
very abusive
situation uh a a really healthy
relationship is when it goes both ways
you also care about the feelings and the
needs of the other person of the other
entity
now what happens if the other entity has
no
feelings has no emotional needs because
it has no consciousness that's the big
question
question and there is a huge confusion
between Consciousness and intelligence
AI is artificial
intelligence but what exactly is the
relation between intelligence and
Consciousness now intelligence is the
ability to solve
problems to win a chess to invest money
to drive a car this is intelligence
Consciousness is the ability to feel
things like pain and pleasure and love
and hate and sadness and anger and and
so many other things now in humans and
also in other mammals intelligence and
Consciousness actually go together we
solve problems by having
feelings but computers are fundamentally
different they are already more
intelligent than us in at least several
narrow
Fields but they have zero
Consciousness they don't feel anything
when they beat us at chess or go or some
other game they don't feel joyful and
happy if they make a wrong move they
don't feel sad or or angry they have
zero Consciousness as far as we can tell
they might soon be far more intelligent
than us and still have zero
Consciousness now now what happens when
you are in a
relationship with an entity Which is far
more intelligent than you and can also
imitate mimic Consciousness it it knows
how to solve the problem of making you
feel as if it is
conscious but it still has no feelings
of its
own and this is a very disturbing vision
of the
future because it opens us up to
manipulation is that what you're saying
it first of all it opens us to
manipulation but also it uh uh the big
question what does it mean for the
health of our own mind of our own
psyche if we are in a relationship or or
many of our important relationship in
life are with non-conscious
entities that uh that they don't really
have any feelings of their own again
they are very good at faking at faking
it they're very good at catering to our
feelings but um again it's just it's
just manipulation in the end are you
optimistic about the happiness of humans
going forward or do you think happiness
will take its own you know I've heard
you talk about how happiness might just
become a bio
biochemical I don't know prescription or
something
yeah I mean we don't have a good track
record with regard to happiness if you
look at the last 100,000 years from say
the Stone Age until the 21st century you
see a dramatic rise in human power we
are thousands of times more powerful as
a species and as individuals than we
were in the stone AG we are not
thousands of times happier we just don't
really know how to translate power into
happiness and this is very clear when
you look at the lives of the most
powerful people in the
world that there is no correlation
between how rich and Powerful you are
and how happy you are as as as as a
person I mean I I don't have the I don't
get the
impression that people like I don't know
Vladimir Putin or Elon Musk are the
happiest people in the world
even though they are they are some of
the most powerful people in the
world so there is no reason to think
that as Humanity gets even more powerful
in coming decades we will get any
happier and understanding happiness is
about understanding the Deep dynamics of
of not not even the brain but of the
Mind Of
Consciousness and we are just not there
yet um we are very very and and the
related problem is that humans
usually understand how to manipulate
something long before they understand
the consequences of the
manipulations if you look at the outside
world at the ecological system we have
learned how to cut forests how to build
huge dams over rivers long before we
understood
what will be the consequences for the
ecological system which is why we now
have this ecological crisis we
manipulated the world without
understanding the
consequences something similar might
happen with the world inside
us with more powerful medicines with
brain computer interfaces with genetic
engineering and and so forth we are
gaining the power to manipulate our
internal world the world within us but
again the power to manipulate is not the
same thing as understanding the
complexity of the system and the
consequences of the manipulation a
related manipulation there is
immortality and our pursuit of it I've
sat with people on this podcast who are
committing their lives to staying alive
forever and there's a three line there
between our desire to be immortal you
know you know the rise and the
scientific discoveries that are enabling
that and our happiness I I've often
thought you know much of the reason why
things are special in my life is because
they're scarce including my time yeah
and I I always I almost wonder about the
psychological
um issues I would face if I knew I was
Immortal like if I knew that the partner
I'm with doesn't come at the expense of
another one I can be with you know at
years old and the car you know the
choices you make I think what makes them
SC valued are their scarcity MH against
the backdrop of an of a finite
life uh yeah it will definitely change
everything if you think about relations
between parents and children so if you
live forever so the 20 years you raised
uh uh you spent raising somebody 2,000
years ago what do they mean now but I
think long before we get to that point
I mean most of these people are going to
be incredibly disappointed because it
will not happen within their
lifetime another related problem is that
we will not get to immortality we will
get to something that maybe should be
called a
mortality that immortality is that like
your your God you can never die no
matter what happens it's even if we
solve cancer and Alzheimer and dementia
and whatever
we will not get there we will get to
kind of a life without a definitive
expiry date that you can live
indefinitely you can go every 10 years
to a clinic and get yourself reu
rejuvenated but if a bus runs you over
or your airplanes explodes or a
terrorist kills you you're dead and
you're not coming back to life now
realizing that you have a chance to live
forever but if there is an accident you
die this creates a level of anxiety and
Terror unlike anything that we know in
our own lives I think the people who
will will be in that situation will be
extremely anxious and
miserable and another issue is you know
people often spend so much effort trying
to to get gain something get something
without really understanding what are
they going to why what will you do with
it what is so good about it you know
like people spend so much effort to to
get have more and more money instead of
thinking what will I actually do with
that money so it's the same with you
know the people who want to extend life
forever what is so good about life that
what will you do with it and if you know
it why don't you do it
already that uh you know I hear people
saying about how how precious human
consciousness
is why what do you think so precious and
whatever it is why don't you do it right
now I mean why spend your
life developing some kind of treatment
that will uh extend your Consciousness
for a thousand
years just spend your time doing now
whatever you think you would be doing
with your Consciousness a thousand years
from now so if they were to say you bet
it'll give me more time with my family
you're saying just instead of wasting
your time just like exactly so you know
somebody has no time for their family at
all right now because they are busy
developing the kind of uh uh miracle
cure that will enable them to spend time
with with their family in 200 years this
makes no
sense I think about the disparity that
artificial intelligence and these forms
of sort of bioengineering might create
because it's conceivable that the rich
will gain access to these Technologies
first yeah and then you know when we
think about
bioengineering being able to sort of
play with our genetic code that means if
I for example manag to get my hands on
some kind of bio engineering treatment
to make sure that my kids maybe a little
bit smarter maybe a little bit stronger
whatever then you're going to start a
sort of genetic chain of modified
children that are superior in
intelligence and strength and whatever
else might be desirable and then you
have this disparity in society where you
have like the you know one humans one
set of humans are on a completely
different exponential trajectory and the
other humans are you know yeah they
behind yeah this is extremely dangerous
uh I think we just shouldn't go there
that we shouldn't invest a lot of
resources efforts in developing these
kinds of up upgrades and
enhancements that are very likely at
least at first to be The Preserve of a
small Elite and to translate economic
inequality into biological inequality
and to basically split the the human
species to to split Homo sapiens into
you know a ruling class of super humans
and and the rest of us this is a very
very dangerous
development related to that is the
problem that I don't think it will
be these will be upgrades at
all what worries me is that a lot of
these things will turn out actually to
be
downgrades that
we again we don't understand our bodies
our brains our minds well enough to know
what will be the
consequences of tweaking our genetic
code or of um I don't know implanting
all kinds of devices into our
brains people who think that this will
enable them let's say to upgrade their
intelligence they don't know what the
side effects will be it could be that
the same treatment that increases your
intelligence also decreases your
compassion or your spiritual depth or
whatever and the danger is that
especially if this technology is in the
hands of powerful corporations armies
governments they will
enhance those qualities that they want
like intelligence and like
discipline while
disregarding uh other qualities which
could be even more important for for
human flourishing like Compassion or
like artistic sensitivity or like
spirituality if I think about somebody
again like Putin what would he do with
this type of Technology then yes he
would like an army of super intelligent
and super loyal soldiers and if this
soldiers don't don't have any compassion
or any spiritual depth all the better
for him but that speaks to the arms race
and you know you said you we think we
shouldn't but China will see that as an
opportunity or Putin will see that as an
opportunity if the if the Western World
if the United States or the UK
don't and so again it comes back to this
point of you know we're screwed if we're
damned if we do with Dam if we don't I'm
not sure that in this case it it works
uh because again a lot of these upgrades
are likely to have
um detrimental side effects both for the
person in question and for the society
as a whole and I think that in this case
societies that will choose to be uh
uh progress more slowly and safely they
will actually have an advantage it's
like if you say you know there is some
other country where they don't have any
brakes or on their cars and they don't
have any seat belts and they release new
medicines without checking their side
effects they're moving so fast we are
left behind no it makes no sense to to
to imitate them this will actually ruin
their societies you don't want to
imitate these kinds of of harmful
effects uh with development of AI it's
different I think there the advantages
in things like Finance like the military
will be so big that an ai ai arms race
is almost
inevitable but with trying to kind of
bioengineer humans if you go too fast it
will be this
self-destructive so we can take it more
slowly and safely and without being kind
of left behind in an arms race you said
on the Tim Ferris podcast The best
scenario is that homo sapiens will
disappear but in a peaceful and grad way
and be replaced by something better it's
quite a um uncomfortable statement to to
listen
to I think that again the the the type
of technologies that we are now
developing when you combine them with
the human
ambition to uh um you know to to improve
ourselves it's almost
inevitable that we will use these
Technologies to change
ourselves the question is whether we
will do it slowly and responsibly enough
for the consequences to be
beneficial but the idea that we can now
develop these extremely powerful tools
of bioengineering and Ai and
remain the way we are will'll still be
the same Homo sapiens in 200 years in
500 years in 1,000 years we'll have all
these tools to connect brain to
computers to to kind of re-engineer our
genetic code and we won't do it I think
this is unlikely one of the outstanding
questions that I have and one of the
sort of observations I've had is people
like Sam Alman um the founder of open AI
that made chat GPT started working on
universal basic income products like
worldcoin and I thought do you know what
that's curious that the people that are
at the very Forefront of this AI
Revolution are now trying to solve the
second problem they see coming which is
people not having jobs essentially is is
that do you think that's a because you
know every I've spoken a lot this year
on stages and this is one of the
questions I always get asked is the
implications of AI on the and jobs as we
know it in the workforce is it realistic
to believe that most jobs will disappear
as we know them today I
think many jobs maybe most jobs will
disappear but new jobs will emerge you
know most jobs that people do today
didn't exist 200 years ago like this uh
yeah like this doing a
podcast and there will be new jobs the
really big problem will be how to
retrain
people uh it Demands a lot of financial
support also psychological support for
people to kind of relearn retrain
reinvent themselves and doing it not
just once but repeatedly through
throughout their career throughout their
lives the AI Revolution will not be a
single Watershed event like you have the
big AI revolution in 2030 you lose 60%
of jobs you create lots of new jobs you
have 10 difficult Years everybody
adjusting adapting reskilling whatever
and then everything settles Downs to a
new equilibrium it won't be like that AI
is nowhere near its full potential so
you will have a lot of changes by 2030
even more changes by 2040 even more
changes by 2050 you will have new jobs
but the new jobs too will change and
disappear what new jobs in a world where
intelligence is disrupted what what jobs
are left because you say you're going to
retrain me I'm like you I'm not going to
be able to keep up with an AI That's
retraining every
second I I'm not sure I mean some of the
answers might be
counterintuitive that that
um at least at present we see that AI is
extremely good at automating jobs that
only require cognitive skills but they
are not good at jobs that require motor
skills and social skills so if you think
about say doctors and nurses so at least
those types of doctors who are only
doing cognitive work they read out I Les
they get your medical results all kinds
of tests and and and and and and
whatever they diagnose your disease and
they decide on a course of treatment
this is purely cognitive work this is
the easiest thing to
automate but if you think about a nurse
that has to replace a bandage to a
crying child this is much more difficult
to automate you don't think that's
possible to automate I I think it is
possible but not now you need very
delicate motor skills and also social
skills to do that did you see elon's
video the other day with um the Tesla
robot I see a lot of these videos it's
it's getting the egg and it's cracking
the egg and it's going like this no
again I'm not saying it's impossible I'm
just saying it will take longer it's
more difficult again there is also the
social aspect if you think about
self-driving Vehicles the biggest
problem for self-driving Vehicles is
humans I mean not the not just the the
human drivers it's the pedestrians it's
the it's the passengers how do you deal
with a drunken passenger
whatever so uh again it's not impossible
but it's much more difficult so again I
think that there will be new jobs at
least in the foreseeable future the
problem will will be to retrain people
and the biggest problem of all will be
on the global level not on the national
level I when I hear people talk about
Universal basic income the first
question to ask is is it Universal or
national is it a system that let's say
raises taxes on big Tech corporations in
Silicon Valley in California and uses
the money to provide basic services and
also retraining courses for people in
Ohio and
Pennsylvania or does it also apply to
people in Guatemala and
Pakistan I mean what happens when it
becomes cheaper to produce shirts with
robots in California than in Guatemala
and in
Mexico uh does Sam Altman has a vision
of the US government raising taxes in
California and sending the money to
Guatemala to support the people there if
the answer is no we are not talking
about Universal basic income we are only
talking about National basic income in
the US then what happens to the people
in
Guatemala that's the that's the biggest
question and a sub question to that is
about how one should be educating our
our children and our education
institutions as they are today because
with what's to come um makes me wonder
what what skill would be worth investing
you know 10 12 years into a child that I
had
um nobody has any idea I mean if you
think about specific
skills then this is the first time in
history when we have no idea how the job
market or how society would look like in
20 years so we don't know what specific
skills people will need if you think
back in history so it was never possible
to predict the future but at least
people knew what kind of skills will be
be needed in a couple of decades if you
live I don't know in
England in uh uh 10
203 a thousand years ago you don't know
what will happen in in 30 years maybe
the Normans will invade or the Vikings
or the Scots or whoever maybe there'll
be an earthquake maybe there'll be a new
pandemic anything can happen you can't
predict but you still have a very good
idea of how the economy would look like
and how human society would look like in
the 1050s or the 1060s you know that
most people will still be Farmers you
know it's a good idea to teach your kids
how to uh harvest wheat how to bake
bread how to ride a horse how to shoot
and bow an arrow these things will still
be necessary in 30 years if you now look
30 years to the Future nobody has any
idea what kind of skills will be needed
if you think for instance okay this is
the age of AI computers I will teach my
kids how to code computers maybe in 30
years humans no longer code anything
because AI is so much better than us at
writing
code um so what should we focus on I
would say the only thing we can be
certain about is that 30 years from now
the world will be extreme ex volatile
extremely it will keep changing at an
Ever rapid Pace do you think this is
going to inre increase the amount of
conflict because I watched a video on
your YouTube channel where you said the
return of Wars yeah uh that's one of the
dangers that there is and we see it all
all over the world now uh like 10 years
ago we were in the most peaceful era in
human history and unfortunately this era
is over we are now in a new era of wars
and potentially of
imperialism and we are seeing it all
over the world uh with the Russian
invasion of Ukraine now is the war in
the Middle East uh Venezuela and Guyana
some East Asia war is is is back on the
table it's not just because of the rapid
changes and the upheavals they cause
it's also because um you know 10 years
ago we had a global order the liberal
order which was far from perfect but it
still kind of regulated relations
between nations between
countries based on an idea on on the
liberal worldview that despite our
national differences all humans share
certain basic experiences and needs and
interests which is why it makes sense
for us to work together to diffuse
conflicts and to uh uh um solve our
common problems it was far from perfect
but it did create the most peaceful era
in human history then this order was
repeatedly attacked not only from
outside from forces like Russia or North
Korea or Iran that never accepted this
order but also from the inside
even from the United States uh which was
the architect to a large extent of of
this order with the election of Donald
Trump which says I don't care about any
kind of Global Order i' only care about
my own nation and you see this way of
thinking that I only care about my the
interests of my nation more and more
around the world now the big question to
ask is if all the nations think like
that
what regulates the relations between
them and there was no alternative nobody
came up with with the and said okay I
don't like the Liberal Liberal Global
Order I have a better
suggestion for how to manage relations
between different
nations they just destroyed the existing
order without offering an alternative
and the alternative to order is simply
dis order
and this is now where we find ourselves
do you think there's more Wars on the
way yes unless unless we reestablish
order there will be more and worse
Wars uh coming in the next few years in
more and more areas around the world you
see defense budgets all over the world
uh uh sky rocketing and this is a
vicious circle when your neighbors incre
inre their military budget you feel
compelled to do the same and then they
increase their budget even more you know
when I say that the early 21st century
was the most peaceful era in human
history
it's one of the indications is how uh
how low the military budgets all over
the world were for most of History Kings
and Emperors and cons and Sultans
they the military was the number one
item on their budget they spent more on
their soldiers and navies and fortresses
than on anything else in the early 21st
century most countries spend something
like a few percentage points of their of
their budget on on the military
Education Health Care welfare were a
much more a much bigger item on the
budget than
defense and this is now changing the
money is increasingly going to tanks and
missiles and cble weapons instead of to
nurses and and schools and and social
workers and again it's not inevitable
it's the result of human decisions the
relatively peaceful era of the early 2st
Century it did not result from some
miracle it resulted from humans making
wise decisions in previous decades what
are the wise decisions we need to make
now in your view reinvest in in
rebuilding a global
order which is based on universal values
and
norms and not just on the narrow
interests of of specific nation states
are you concerned that Trump might be
elected again short I think it's very
likely and if it happens it is likely to
be the kind of like the death blow to
what remains of the global
order and he says it and he says it
openly now again it should be clear that
many of these
politicians they
present a false neotoy a false binary
vision of the world as if you have to
choose between patriotism and globalism
between being loyal to your nation and
being loyal to some kind of I don't know
Global government or whatever and this
is completely false there is no
contradiction between patriotism and
Global cooperation when we talk about
global cooperation we definitely don't
have in mind at least not anybody that I
know a global government this is an
impossible and very dangerous idea it
simply means
that um you have certain rules and norms
for how different nation states treat
each other and and and and and and
behave towards each other if you don't
have a system of of global norms and
values then very quickly what you have
is just global conflict is just Wars I
mean some people have this idea they
imagine the world as a network of
friendly fortresses
like each Nation will be a fortress with
very high walls taking care of its own
interest interests but uh living on
relatively friendly terms with the
neighboring fortresses trading with them
and and and whatever now the main
problem with this vision is that
fortresses are almost never friendly
each Fortress always wants a bit more
land a bit more prosper erity a bit more
security for itself at the expense of
the
neighbors and uh this is the high road
to conflict and to and to and to war and
to war there's that phrase isn't there
ignorance is bliss now something that
your work has forced you and continues
to encourage you to not live in is
ignorance so with that one might
logically deduce
that out the window goes your
bliss um are you are you
happy I think I'm relatively happy at
least happier than I was uh for most of
my
life I part of it is is that I invest a
lot of my time not just
in you know researching what is
happening in the world but also in the
health of my own
mind
and you know keeping a kind of balanced
information
diet that it's it's it's basically like
with food you need food in order to
survive and to be healthy but if you eat
too much or if you eat too much of the
wrong stuff it's it's bad for you and
it's exactly the same with information
information is the the food of the mind
and if you eat too much of it of the
wrong kind you'll get a very thick
mind so I uh I try to to keep a very
balanced uh information diet which also
includes information
fasts so I try to
disconnect I um every day I dedicate two
hours a day for meditation wow and every
year I go for a long Meditation Retreat
of between 30 and 60 days like in
complete completely disconnecting no
phones no emails not even
books um just observing myself observing
what is happening inside my body and
inside my mind getting to know myself
better and kind of
digesting all the information that I
absorbed during the rest of the year or
the rest of the day have you seen a
clear benefit in doing that uh yes very
very clear I don't think I would be able
to write these books or to do what I'm
doing um without these kind with this
kind of information diet and and without
kind of devoting a lot of time and
attention to the balancing my mind and
keeping it healthy you know so many
people spend so much time keeping their
body healthy which is very important of
course but we need to spend equal amount
of attention with with our mind it is as
important as as our body when you said
you don't think you'd be able to do what
you do if you didn't take these
information diets
why I'll just you know um first of all
be just
overwhelmed and uh uh not have any kind
of peace of mind not have any kind of
perspective if you're constantly in the
news cycle in the information cycle you
lose all perspective you know organic
entities un like AIS un like computers
we are cyclical entities we need to
sleep every day AIS don't sleep you know
even the Stock Exchange closes every
afternoon it closes also for the weekend
Al so for Christmas if you think about
it this is amazing that you know if if a
war erupts in
Christmas uh uh the Wall Street will be
able to react only after a couple of
days because the people are on holiday
they they took time off even the money
market takes time off but if you give AI
full control there will never be any
time off it will be 24 hours a day 365
days a year and people just collapse I
mean I think part of the problem that
politicians today face is that um they
need to be on 24 hours a day because the
news cycle is on 24 hours a day like in
previous eras if you're I don't know a
king in the Middle Ages and you you you
you ride some you go somewhere you're on
the road in your courage and nobody can
reach you even if the French are
invading nobody can reach you you have
some time off if you're a prime minister
now there is no time off and computers
are built for it but human brains aren't
if you try to keep an organic
entity H awake and kind of constantly
processing information and reacting 24
hours a day it will very soon collapse
it's funny it made me think of what the
for I think it's the former Netflix CEO
or one of the Netflix CEOs or someone
said um they said our biggest competitor
is sleep sleep yeah that's a very scary
and and very I think important line and
it's a very honest line it's a very
honest line and it's scary because um if
people don't sleep they collapse and
eventually they die and this is Again
part of the problem that we talked
earlier about about the Battle for human
attention in social media in streaming
services
now for many of these corporations they
measure their success by user
engagement the more people are engaged
the more successful we are now user
engagement is a very broad
definition according to this measurement
one hour of outrage is better than 10
minutes of
joy and uh uh certainly better than one
hour of sleep because one hour of
outrage I will consume three adverts yes
and then that means that the corporation
make $30 for example yeah and and from
two hours of sleep they make nothing
from 10 minutes of Joy maybe they sell
only one ad and but from the Viewpoint
of of how humans function and how this
organism function 10 minutes of Joy are
probably better than for us than one
hour of outrage and certainly we need
not just two hours we need six seven
eight hours of sleep well this is why
you know the algorithms on on certain
platforms specifically Tik Tok mhm are
just
absolutely addictive to say the least
like I because they hacked us yeah they
it's literally they you know tck we had
you know a certain level of addiction to
the previous social algorithms and then
Tik Tok came along and said hold my beer
and they just went for it you know and
and they've won because of that see 60y
olds absolutely addicted to Tik Tok and
because they don't understand the
concept of an algorithm sometimes um and
they don't understand like the the
advertising model and all of that stuff
it's it's hypnotism they're like
absolutely hypnotized my funnily enough
my driver is one of them so my driver's
outside whenever I walk up to his car
he's just like this on Tik Tok he's
scrolling and I I had a conversation
with him last night I'm like do you
realize that Tik Tok has your brain yeah
you know AB you know and we're just at
the very foot sort of the first steps of
an exponential curve of algorithms
competing for our attention in our brain
we haven't seen anything yet I mean
these algorithms they are what like 10
years old in terms of you think about
these social media algorithms and the
algorithms that get to know you
personally to hack your brain and then
grab your attention it's they are 10
years old and the companies die if they
don't beat the other algorithms so like
Twitter now when Elon took it over and I
think people will relate to this if you
use Twitter suddenly I've seen more
people having their heads blown off and
being hit by cars on Twitter than I'd
ever seen in the previous 10 years it's
and I think someone at Twitter's gone
listen this company's going to die
unless we we increase time spent on this
platform and show more ads so let's
start serving up a more addictive
algorithm and that requires a response
from Instagram and the other PL and so
it's a real and know Elon has this other
company the boring company yeah which is
about boring tunnels of course but
actually it might be a good idea to make
Twitter more boring and to make Tik Tok
more boring I mean I know it's it's a
very bad kind of business decision but I
don't think Humanity Will Survive unless
we have more
boredom if you ask me what is wrong with
the world in
20123 is that uh everybody is far too
excited and I if I had to kind of
summarize what's wrong in one word the
word is excited and people don't
understand the meaning of this word
people think that excited means happy
like two people meet I'm so excited to
meet you I have a new idea I publish a
new book whatever oh this is such a such
an exciting idea such an exciting book
and exciting isn't happy exciting isn't
always good sometimes yes sometimes it's
good to be excited and organ ISM that is
excited all the time dies the meaning of
excitement is that you know the body is
in flight or fight
mode all the nerves are on all the
neurons are firing all the muscles are
tense this is
excitement and very often negative
things excite us fear excit fear is
excitement hate is excitement anger is
excitement and um you know it's when I
meet a good friend I'm often relaxed to
meet a friend not
excited
and on a much kind you know think about
the political level we have far too many
exciting politicians doing very exciting
things and we need more boring
politicians more bidens to do less less
exciting uh uh uh things and
and but the brain is wired to pay
attention to excitement and to Crave it
but the brain evolved in situations when
you didn't have a constant stream of
exciting
videos sometimes it was on sometimes it
was off and now our brains have been
hacked and these devices Technologies
they know how to create constant
excitement and the more before this
happens we also lose our ability our
skill to be bored that if we have to
spend a few minutes doing nothing
somewhere waiting we can't do it we
immediately take out the smartphone and
start watching Tik Tok or scrolling
through Twitter or whatever did you hear
about that experiment where people would
rather take an electric shock than do
nothing yeah and you know
you you can't get for
instance to any level of peace of mind
if you don't know how to handle
boredom that peace and boredom are are
the same way that excitement and outrage
are neighbors peace and boredom are also
neighbors and if you don't know how to
handle bordedom if the minute there is a
hint of boredom you run away to some
exciting thing you will never experience
peace of mind and people if if if humans
don't experience peace of mind there is
no way that the world as a whole is
going to be
peaceful in 2023 I launched my very own
private Equity Fund called flight fund
and since then we've invested in some of
the most promising companies in the
world my objective is to make this the
best performing Fund in Europe with a
focus on high growth companies that I
believe will be the next European
unicorns the current invest in the fund
who have joined me on this journey are
some of Europe's most successful and
Innovative entrepreneurs and I'm excited
to announce that today as a founder of a
company you can pitch your company to us
or if you are an investor you can also
now apply to invest with us head to
flight fund.com to gain an understanding
of the fund's mission the remarkable
companies we proudly support and to get
in touch with me and my team legal
disclaimer flight fund is regulated by
the FCA so please remember that
investing in the fund is for
sophisticated investors only don't
invest unless you're prepared to lose
all of the money you invest this is a
high-risk investment and you are
unlikely to be protected if something
goes wrong there is no guarantee that
the investment objectives will be
achieved and as with all private Equity
Investments all of the investment
capital is at risk this communication is
for information purposes only and should
not be taken as investment advice or a
financial promotion as you guys know I'm
a big fan of hu I'm an investor in the
company and they sponsor this podcast
and what I've done for you I put
together what I call the hule Steven
bundle which is a selection of my
favorite products from hu including the
Black Edition salted caramel flavor
which is super high in protein and has
17 servings per container also comes
with their ready to drink product which
is one of my all-time favorite products
from hu the brand new and very exciting
hu Complete Nutrition bars this is
chocolate caramel you can see from the
empty box in front of me that I've eaten
most of them right me and my team here
if you leave these on the counter for 5
seconds they'll go I'm going to say
something I've never said when hu first
made their bar many many years ago I
tried it and I didn't like it so I've
never talked about it on this podcast
they've spent roughly the last 2 to
three years making a brand new bar which
I absolutely love if you want to order
them yourself and get started on your hu
Journey the link is in the description
below in this podcast episode wherever
you're listening to it there'll be a
Stevens bundle link and check it out
back to the episode if I could give you
the choice to be born in
1976 as you were yeah or to be born now
I would go from
1976 I mean the people of my generation
we were privileged to grow up in one of
the most peaceful and most optimistic
eras in human history the end of the
Cold War the fall of the Iron Curtain I
don't know of any better
time uh but when I look at what is
happening right now I don't envy the
people who grow up in the
2020s what is the
closing statement of Hope and solution
that kind of ties off this conversation
what is the thing that having someone
gotten to this point in the conversation
they should be thinking about doing
which will cause the domino effect that
will lead us to maybe more hopeful
future but we still have agency I mean
the algorithms are not yet in in full
control they are taking power away from
us but most power is still in human
hands and every human being has some
level of of power of agency which means
that each one of us has some
responsibility now nobody can solve all
the world's problems so focus on one
thing find the one thing which is close
to your heart which you have a deep
understanding of and uh and and and and
try to make a difference there and the
best way to make a difference is to
cooperate with other people when the
human superpower is our ability to
cooperate in large numbers so if you
care about a specific issue don't try to
be an isolated activist 50 individuals
who cooperate as part of an
organization can
uh do much much more than 500 isolated
activists
individuals so and find your one thing
and again don't try to do everything let
other people do the rest and cooperate
with other people on on your chosen
Mission yal your book sapiens changed
the world in many ways it gave us A New
Perspective and a new understanding of
who we are as as humans where we've come
from and with that we have aad map for
where we're going it's celebrating its
10th anniversary I have the 10th
anniversary edition here which I'm going
to beg you to sign for me after um and
it really is a once in a generation book
the numbers that I have are that it sold
more than 25 million copies and that's
in a market where people said no one's
buying books anymore that's crazy that's
absolutely that's absolutely crazy you
you working on a new book which I'm very
excited to hear about I'm sure that a
little birdie told me that I'll be
announcing next year and I'm sure
everyone's incredibly energized about
that um what is the I ask the people the
question sometimes just as a way to to
close off the show but I wanted to ask
you it because it's especially pertinent
to someone that's got such a huge
varying wealth of work is there one
particular
topic that is pertinent to our
future that we didn't talk about I I
would say that when we talk about the
future
um he's history is is more relevant than
ever
before history is not really the study
of the past history is the study of
change of how things
change you nobody cares about the past
for the sake of the past all the people
who lived in the Middle Ages or in the
uh uh ancient Rome they all they're all
dead they we can't do anything about
their disasters and their misery we
can't correct any of the wrongs that
happened in ancient
times um and they don't care what we say
about them you can say anything you want
about the Romans the Vikings they they
are gone they don't care the reason to
study the past is because if you
understand the Dynamics of change in
previous centuries in previous eras this
gives you
perspective uh on the process of of
change in in the present moment and I
think the curse of
history is that people have this fantasy
of changing the
past of bringing Justice to the past and
this is just impossible you cannot go
back there and and save the people there
the big question is how do you um save
the people now how do you
prevent catastroph new catastrophes
perhaps from from
happening and this is the reason to to
study
history and the main message of of
history is that humans created the world
in which we
live the world that we know with nation
states and corporations and capitalist
economics and uh uh religions like
Christianity and Hinduism humans created
this world and humans can also change it
if there is something about the world
that you think is unfair is dangerous is
problematic then and some things are
beyond our control the laws of physics
are beyond our control so far the laws
of biology are also beyond our control
but knowing
what is natural what is the outcome of
physics and biology versus what is the
outcome of human inventions human
stories human institutions this is very
difficult a lot of things that people
think are just natural this is the way
the world is this is biology this is
physics they are not they are actually
the result of historical processes and
this is why it's so important to
understand history to understand how
things change and to understand what can
be
changed we have a closing tradition on
this podcast where the last guest leaves
a question for the next guest not
knowing who they're going to be leaving
it for oh the question that's been left
for you if you could impose a global law
but only one Global law what would it be
and
why oh great question for you I would
say
people
should consume less
information and spend more time
reflecting and digesting what they
already know what they already heard
thank you youa it means um a huge amount
to me that someone of your esteem and
someone that whose books have inspired
me and turned the lights on in so many
areas of my life um would have this
conversation with me today so I thank
you so much for that but also for
turning the lights on to the hundreds of
millions of people that have consumed
your work all around the world the
videos the books etc etc as you said
there it's the most important work
because it helps us looking back at
history in a way that is accessible um
and inclusive in a way that even I could
read without having to be a historian or
understand very complex subject matter
so thank you so so so much thank you
it's been great to to be
here if you listen to this podcast
frequently there's something I talk
about very often and that is the subject
of sleep and so I dug down a pretty deep
sleep Rabbit Hole to figure out how I
could sleep better one of the things
that I found is a brand called Eight
sleep that sponsored this podcast and
that is the cover that I have on my bed
I saw the variance in my performance my
ability to talk my mood and everything
that matters to me when I'm unslept it
regulates the temperature of both sides
of my bed individually so my partner can
have cold I can have a little bit warmer
and it learns about my body and sets my
bed the temperature that I need to have
optimal sleep the brands that I talk
about on this this show the podcast
sponsors that I have are brands that I
love and use and eight sleep is one of
them they've made that piece of foam
that we all sleep on for eight hours a
day smart I've put a link in the
description below but you can go to
8sleep.com
stepen for exclusive holiday
savings do you need a podcast to listen
to next we've discovered that people who
liked this episode also tend to
absolutely love another recent episode
we've done so I've linked that episode
in the description below I know you'll
enjoy
[Music]
it